[SPEAKER_00]: Second of Wales son, around noon, Jude and Paul Rivero sit together in a small study in the royal palace of Prince Jeon discussing the future of their collaborations.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, Prince Jeon's your uncle?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mom's side?
[SPEAKER_01]: Dad's side?
[SPEAKER_01]: My mom's side.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I tell by his physique?
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he seem to walk like a youngish 20-something?
He...
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you can't see his face, but he's...
[SPEAKER_00]: He looks like a strapping Oeridian, I would say not bulky, but he looks kind of like the same form of Jeon, kind of younger than him, not as muscular yet, but he could grow into it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Lord Jamis must be your godfather?
[SPEAKER_01]: I feel a slight disadvantage given that you have a mask.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where did you get that mask?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's interesting.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know it is.
[SPEAKER_02]: You have it custom made?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not affiliated with the monks.
[SPEAKER_01]: So where did you get the mask?
[SPEAKER_02]: I bought it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think I've ever seen those outside of the monks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Monastery.
[SPEAKER_02]: One of a kind.
Hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's comfortable.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, all right, so if I'm supposed to keep you alive, I hope that that sentiment is
[SPEAKER_01]: Also reversed.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hope you're interested in keeping me alive.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have only been here for a week, maybe a little bit more, but the only leads that I have is I was looking into places that Lord Phranck had stopped, one of which was an Alchemist shop.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I was followed when I went there.
[SPEAKER_02]: What part of town?
[SPEAKER_01]: I described the part of town.
[SPEAKER_01]: The foreign district.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_02]: That makes sense.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it was not, it was somebody that was invisible.
[SPEAKER_01]: That doesn't necessarily mean it was a regular.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was able to go invisible myself, and that's how I lost them, to the best of my knowledge.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it was somebody that was capable.
[SPEAKER_01]: And as we were just discussing with Prince Jeon and Lord Jamis, the assassins tend to like mix magic.
[SPEAKER_01]: So now
[SPEAKER_01]: The only thing that I can think of being new to the foreign district within the last two weeks, new to Monmurg or back to Monmurg, I've been to Monmurg before, but I don't think anything in my history at least would have tied me to this recent political problems.
[SPEAKER_01]: I had run out of an inn, Ferd's Inn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you familiar in the foreign district with Ferd's Inn?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't believe so.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a place that I had stayed with before when I was here years and years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I had run out and humiliated and almost killed, probably should have killed, a ruffian.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so I don't know if I was followed simply the knife in the back because of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that might be something that's like, you know, neither here nor there.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the fact that the individual was able to make themselves invisible, which I definitely detected, might suggest that if it was the ruffian, he might have thought that I was an easy kill because I had blasted him in order to get my own room back, which... People are always getting stabbed every day in the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but I can't imagine that they're turning themselves invisible to do the stabbing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Would you agree?
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe true.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that may be something, it may be nothing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Regardless,
[SPEAKER_01]: I purchased a still, and I plan to try to use some street urchins to, and you might be able to facilitate this, this is completely aside, it's more of the Mon game.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want, given that there's going to be a food shortage, or already has been a food shortage in the city of Monmurg, people will turn towards anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I can get the cast-offs from the noble families, orange peels, things like that, half-turned apples, things like that, I can certainly start to use this still.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we can make Ferd's place into a place where people can do alcohol, and when people are drunk they tend to talk.
[SPEAKER_01]: Once again, that's more of the long game.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the long game could be more like a month from now, depending upon if we can get food shipped on Sunday.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is it that we should take the lead, or I should take the lead from you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Prince Jeanne?
[SPEAKER_02]: I've got some quicker leads, probably.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hopefully at least.
[SPEAKER_02]: And quicker routes at least, too.
[SPEAKER_02]: Last night I got attacked while strolling through the foreign trade district.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bye.
[SPEAKER_02]: I haven't met them yet, but there were just two bums that were trying to rob me.
[SPEAKER_02]: I shot one with the arrow in the neck.
[SPEAKER_02]: He fell to the floor.
[SPEAKER_02]: The other ran away.
[SPEAKER_02]: I grabbed and have the other one in my dungeon.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm hoping I can use him as a connection.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have a dungeon?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it's like a family.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's the road.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sorry, I forgot.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am of nobility.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, it's not like I go down there every day.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you have a gentleman down there currently?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alive?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Being a soldier?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's fresh.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm hoping they can use him as an inside connection to at least get some...
[SPEAKER_02]: To get at least connections to other people.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have to imagine with the whole mask thing you're kind of easily recognized.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have a lot of enemies?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not really.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hard to have an enemy, you can't see.
[SPEAKER_01]: You still haven't told me where you got that mask?
[SPEAKER_01]: I have bought it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You bought it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just down at the local flea market?
[SPEAKER_01]: Used?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, kind of actually.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, so would you like us to go question your man?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I also have a homoculi.
[SPEAKER_02]: And a homoculi is...
[SPEAKER_02]: I know what a homoculi is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I have that, so... That'll be a lot easier than your... Get the bar...
[SPEAKER_02]: Pause.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's a homoculi?
[SPEAKER_01]: I know I should know, but I can't remember exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll arcana.
[SPEAKER_01]: Damn it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Isn't it like a... Dude, that's gonna be so awesome if you don't know an homoculi.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm trying to figure out...
[SPEAKER_00]: He knows what it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I'm trying to figure out how much you know of what you know of.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, that'd be funny if you didn't know it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twelve plus Arcana.
[SPEAKER_01]: You said Arcana?
[SPEAKER_01]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: Armoncula is a legendary creature that has created... Transmuters would create this.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like a facsimile, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's basically a little creature you create.
[SPEAKER_00]: That does your bidding.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's kind of like a familiar, except the magnum opus was supposedly supposed to describe this.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a little imp, a little creature made out of, there are legends about it being made out of clay, manure, sperm, blood, all these weird things.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's some human- Dude, I read that in the book and I'm like, what?
[SPEAKER_02]: You did not say that.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's some disgusting human- You just said blood.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was like, what in the world is all this other stuff giving you this?
[SPEAKER_02]: You have no idea what I left out.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you have a Munchi alive?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he did.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is he watching him?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it's in my pocket.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just saying it's a lot quicker and easier than your get-the-bar-beer-to-get-everyone-drunk plan, in my opinion at least.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just saying.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, to each his own.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's try your tactics.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what do you want to do with your homunculi while we're questioning your assailant?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, we'll have to drop it off there first.
[SPEAKER_02]: Drop it off where?
[SPEAKER_01]: To the foreign district?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, we have to take it and drop it off in the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we can look for people.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your homunculi can just do...
[SPEAKER_01]: I've never had one.
[SPEAKER_02]: So basically you can take a homunculi, and basically I can see through its eyes and hear through its mouth, like ears and stuff, and I can move and crawl around.
[SPEAKER_01]: So why do you want to lose him in the form district?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, that's kind of a... No, I don't want to lose him, it's just I don't want to...
[SPEAKER_01]: I meant lose him, not lose.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lose him in the form district.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because that's where we're going to find and listen to the conversations that we need to listen to.
[SPEAKER_02]: But we can't exactly just stroll right up on them.
[SPEAKER_02]: This homoculi is about that big.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, that's great.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is he invisible?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, but with how small he is.
[SPEAKER_02]: He goes unnoticed.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's black.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like a black little lizard.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's super fast.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, I've used it around here and no one's found it yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I still have my frog?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do not mention this to Horde Janus, either.
[SPEAKER_02]: Horde Janus.
[SPEAKER_02]: Horde Janus?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: The homunculi, please.
[SPEAKER_01]: Only if you tell me who helped you get the homunculi.
[SPEAKER_02]: The magnum opus.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's a magnum opus?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that like the palace?
[SPEAKER_01]: Dude, what kind of wizard are you?
[SPEAKER_00]: If you don't know the magnum opus... Magnum opus was written by Ujur Udias a thousand years ago, a great human transmuter.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know this, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: The current version has no mention of Immunculae in it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess what I'm asking is that...
[SPEAKER_01]: Who helped create the Humunculae?
[SPEAKER_01]: He created one himself?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not that hard to do, bro.
[SPEAKER_01]: My eyes get narrow.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, personally, never had a Humunculae.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know that I would just set it free in the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you've got to give it something more specific to do than just carouse bars and being a little lizard or whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus, if it's anything like a familiar, you don't want it to get caught.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I mean, do you have an idea of where you want to have them investigate in the foreign district?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, not yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's why we're going to go talk to the guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would suggest you send your homuncula in ahead of us to see what's going on with that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because if they're traitors, he may be being assassinated right now before he can talk.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just saying.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it might not have been anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: It sounds like it was a pretty inept attempt to kill you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: It was just very weak.
[SPEAKER_02]: And to be honest, I don't know if this guy will help us at all, or can, even if he wanted to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, everybody can potentially help us.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's just whether or not they have the right motivation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Something is better than nothing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I agree.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, I'll put my homoculi down there then.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would keep him on a short leash.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep him in front of us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let us know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep him behind us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let us know if anybody's sneaking up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think that it's...
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, the foreign districts... No, I'm gonna send him down to the dungeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's, yeah, that's what I meant.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pull my hamakua out, set on the table.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ooh, I pay close attention.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy pulls out a little dessert.
[SPEAKER_00]: Upon closer examination, it's a clay construct with little wings, and he puts this thing down on the table.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does he speak to it in a certain language, or is it like thought?
[SPEAKER_02]: He just puts it on the table.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you want it to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's just sitting there right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I want it to go down to the table.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do an inch it.
[SPEAKER_00]: How well do you know this guy?
[SPEAKER_00]: What?
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude?
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not long.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want her to know all your secrets?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, not really.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've been avoiding most of the stuff, especially in the beginning about the whole family thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know what that was about.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, at this point, you just put down the homoculi.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's just a clay little figure right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to show him?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you can show him that you're powerful if you want to do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's up to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm not saying it's the best thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or you could kind of make him think you're crazy just by having this little play figure there.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know what I'm saying?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's up to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, let's just send him down for a bunch.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you want Jude to see Democuli crawl off.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't really care if he does or doesn't.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, when the wine comes, they ask for cheese.
[SPEAKER_00]: So the wine definitely comes, but what happens is this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul puts this little creature down the table and it moves.
[SPEAKER_00]: It actually crawls through the table and flies off.
[SPEAKER_00]: It claws onto the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it can't completely fly?
[SPEAKER_01]: Eh, I would say...
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's one of those lizards that glides from tree to tree.
[SPEAKER_02]: It kind of glides, basically.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just checking out its log and its capabilities.
[SPEAKER_01]: Never had one.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then it crawls under the door and disappears.
[SPEAKER_00]: So...
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll an inside check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude nods and goes, hmm, interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: You do that on your own?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: No help or guidance?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, what are you asking?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just curious.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nothing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, how much time do you want to give him before we follow him?
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude is making a mess.
[SPEAKER_00]: Acting strangely nervous as he cuts the cheese.
[SPEAKER_00]: Drink with his wine.
[SPEAKER_01]: So how long do we give him before we go ahead and go down?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you can see through his eyes, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm walking right down the halls right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: All of the other senses, too?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Smell?
[SPEAKER_01]: Say, you know, hear?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I smell, actually?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I get to the dungeon?
[SPEAKER_00]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: The guards are pacing back and forth.
[SPEAKER_00]: You look into the cell of the prisoner.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's only one prisoner.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's there, just kind of sitting in the corner, just kind of sitting there muttering to himself, young man, dirty hair, bad teeth, hard life as peasants have in the district.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, let's just sit for 20 minutes and see if anything happens.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you and Paul sit there.
[SPEAKER_01]: After 10 minutes, I'm on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, is he talking to himself?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he's just muttering random nonsense to himself, nothing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anything you can make out?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is he crazy or...?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, nothing like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's like, basically...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm screwed.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna get hanged.
[SPEAKER_00]: They get cut off my hand.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, he's a royal.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're not gonna cut off my hand.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're gonna cut off my dick.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then kill me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, nothing.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's just terrified.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to do the questioning or not?
[SPEAKER_01]: If I can glower and, you know...
[SPEAKER_01]: What do we need to question him about?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean... You said it wasn't a serious attempt.
[SPEAKER_01]: Had you done anything to piss anyone off?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they specifically came at you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, actually, was there a they, or was there...
[SPEAKER_02]: It was just two guys, to be honest.
[SPEAKER_01]: What happened with the shotgun?
[SPEAKER_02]: Ran away after the arrow hit his friend in the throat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you think it was just a muggy?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: A trumpet muggy?
[SPEAKER_01]: Then we want to recruit him.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I don't have a bunch of booze yet, as you pointed out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's probably going to take too long.
[SPEAKER_01]: How will you get in touch with him?
[SPEAKER_01]: This all needs to be figured out before.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't want him making any suggestions whatsoever.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, because we obviously can't trust him, but you might be able to use him still.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll have him report to me probably every...
[SPEAKER_01]: I know, but where?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, that has to be worked out ahead of time.
[SPEAKER_01]: How?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it's not like he's gonna stroll up to Prince Jeon's palace and be like, yo, I wanna talk to Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, it can be at that bar place you were talking about.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's fitting.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's got to know it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess I've already got exposure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's going to be in the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where was this when it happened?
[SPEAKER_01]: Were you in the foreign district when they tried to kill you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was just outside of the... Do we even know, is he a local or a foreigner?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's obviously a person from Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's from Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: One of the locals that lives in the foreign district, but you know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Should we have him report to us every day or two days or three days?
[SPEAKER_01]: We need more leverage on him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Besides just pay, because they'll just sell it out to somebody else.
[SPEAKER_01]: Besides that, he's probably already thinking he's gonna get his dick cut off and whatever about you rich people.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't like the rest of my family.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, we need to know, um... Well, I mean, don't you rich people take hostages?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, we can.
[SPEAKER_02]: We can do whatever we want.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, within reason, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: I hate to think I'm on the bad guy side.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, well, um...
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, we can threaten his family, but I don't know if he's got a family.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't even know this guy's name, so... Well, we can assume that he has a family.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can assume that... You know what we can give him.
[SPEAKER_01]: What?
[SPEAKER_02]: What everyone else wants, food.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that your homunculus needs to follow him after we make the deal to confirm possibly whatever it is that he's told us.
[SPEAKER_01]: He'll either go to sell us out immediately, which will connect us to the next possible person.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or he'll go flee home and try to, you know, lay low for a couple days, of which we'll get more leverage on him.
[SPEAKER_01]: So either he goes to the bad guys or he tries to go to ground, and as long as your homunculus can follow him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is your homunculus invisible to people, or do they get to see him too?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, they can, but...
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you saw it, so it's not exactly bright and shiny colors.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The dummy gets paid to give you information.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're going to assume that it's going to be crap.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's going to ask information for what for.
[SPEAKER_01]: We want to know all non, well, foreigners.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a seaport.
[SPEAKER_01]: We want to know specifically if there's any Toli rats.
[SPEAKER_01]: And say it to them like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Use the term Toli rat.
[SPEAKER_01]: I won't say anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll just stay kind of in the background.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, do you have an extra mask on you?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll let you do the talking.
[SPEAKER_02]: He'll recognize me and he'll be afraid even more if I just stand there behind you in silence.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: But do you still want that basket?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have an extra one?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Damn it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, these are cool, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: You know why I got it, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: How far does my...
[SPEAKER_00]: Who did Cloak go forward?
[SPEAKER_00]: Your Cloak goes forward, you know, Emperor Palpatine style.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so he can't tell I'm an elf.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe, you know, shaded features.
[SPEAKER_00]: If he was good with the accents, he might be able to tell you enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it sounds like you think it was largely a mugging.
[SPEAKER_01]: Any reason to suspect anything more than just a bullshit mugging?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it wasn't really calculated.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just two guys in the alleyway.
[SPEAKER_01]: Total spontaneous?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Zero chance of success?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, they haven't.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, if you were one of them, would you have thought that that was a good idea?
[SPEAKER_02]: Probably not.
[SPEAKER_01]: So do you think maybe somebody put them up to it?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think they're just trying to rob me for anything of value.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then just rank stupidity.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Somebody walking around in this mask.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously an easy target.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, look at the pissed off guy with a scary mask.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's go fuck with that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's go fuck with that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean... Do you always wear masks?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it probably your thing?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know exactly what my thing is, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean like...
[SPEAKER_01]: You're Prince Jeanne's nephew.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does everybody know about the mask-wearing nephew that kind of roams the back alleys of Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or are you kind of new on the scene?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, no one really pays attention to me if you're asking.
[SPEAKER_01]: So people don't quake when you show up, they don't pee themselves, and you don't have a long list of enemies.
[SPEAKER_02]: To your knowledge.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have a sixth charisma.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, don't say that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Say it in a different way.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am...
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't hang out with my family.
[SPEAKER_02]: I usually keep to myself, if that's what you're wondering.
[SPEAKER_01]: You prefer the company of the streets, the regular.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, not even them either?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was going to say, I kind of know what you mean.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've been hanging out with some riffraff myself.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I mean, Jeon hasn't really wanted to let me out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because ever since my mother passed...
[SPEAKER_01]: But does he use you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because he just introduced you.
[SPEAKER_01]: He doesn't want to use me.
[SPEAKER_02]: He hasn't wanted to.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you still do your own thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I wanted to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, yes, I guess I'm new to the streets, but... Alright, keep your homunculus back.
[SPEAKER_01]: If he's not saying much...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll just keep him there and pick him up on the way out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just keep him back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep him ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we'll escort him.
[SPEAKER_01]: What district are we in?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're in the royal district.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you're up there.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're in a castle.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're in the royal castle.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what we'll do is we'll have the guards.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're going to have to beat the crap out of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll tell them that they're going to beat the crap out of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because the guards always beat the crap out of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, before he gets released, but we'll have the guards escort him back out to... Was it the foreign district that this happened?
[SPEAKER_02]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they drop him off right where I left him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Somebody will beat the crap out of him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably two or three different groups of guards will beat the crap out of him.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then they'll kick him out into the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's how it'll get released.
[SPEAKER_02]: Your homunculus will kind of track them.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then we track them to his home.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or to something more significant.
[SPEAKER_01]: You never want to, like, you may have been tested.
[SPEAKER_01]: You may have been tested.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they may have sent some, like, you know, complete greetings to kind of, like, you know, fuck with you, and somebody might have been insulting you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't ever, like, underestimate your enemy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, best-case scenario, I mean, maybe not best-case scenario for us,
[SPEAKER_01]: But for you, yeah, you know, you're on the street, you're wearing a mask, people thought you were a re-nob.
[SPEAKER_01]: No big deal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he know what a re-nob means?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I probably know what a re-nob means.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, he doesn't.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, I move right along.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I move right along.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you're gonna just blower?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like through your mouth, like, you know, I don't know, give him the eyes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you want me to do the talking?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's do this.
[SPEAKER_00]: So Jude takes his last gulp of wine, eats a piece of cheese.
[SPEAKER_00]: By the way, this is the best shit you've had in weeks since you've been in the city.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you want to make sure, even though you're an elf.
[SPEAKER_00]: They keep giving me crap.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the two of you walk down to the dungeon.